THEY JUST ADDED A POLICY SUCTION
AT HER WEBSITE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S
RUNNING, BUT SHE VERY WELL COULD
RUN.
TO JUDGE THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
2020 HEAVILY CAMPAIGN, WE ARE
JOINED BY A MAN WHO HAS SERVED
FOR DECADES.
BUT TO SEE YOU.
I AM ASSUMING WHAT I JUST SAID
AND WHAT WE ARE HEARING IS TRUE.
IF SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS THE BEST
POSITION TO BE DONALD TRUMP SHE
WOULD GET IN THE RACE.
>> I WOULD TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
MACEDONIAN PARTS.
SHE RAN FOR PRESIDENT BECAUSE
SHE THOUGHT SHE WOULD BE THE
BEST PERSON.
IF SHE STILL THOUGHT THAT NOW,
IF SHE THOUGHT SHE HAD THE BEST
ODDS OF BEATING DONALD TRUMP I
THINK SHE WOULD THINK ABOUT IT
LONG AND HARD.
>> Tucker: REALLY THE QUESTION
AND THAT DOESN'T SURPRISE
ANYBODY.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS, HAS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHANGED SO MUCH
AND THE LAST THREE YEARS THAT IT
WOULD BE POSSIBLE FOR
HILLARY CLINTON TO GET THE
NOMINATION?
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS SAY
HILLARY CLINTON IS THE REAL
PRESIDENT, IT WAS STOLEN, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME YOU THINK MAY BE
THEY HAVE CHANGED AND THEY DON'T
WANT HER ANYMORE.
MAYBE SHE IS TO RIGHT WING.
>> THIS IS A HUGE IF, BUT IF SHE
WOULD JUMP IN AND THE PARTY HAS
MOVED SOMEPLACE THAT SHE HASN'T,
SHE WILL GET THE VOTES.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THE PRIMARY.
THERE ARE STILL 19 PEOPLE, A FEW
THAT ARE DOUBLE DIGITS.
IF SHE WOULD RUN AND PEOPLE
WOULD THINK SHE IS TO LEFT, TO
LEFT, TO CENTER, THAT'S THE
BEAUTY OF IT.
THEY GET TO VOTE AGAINST
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
I DON'T KNOW.
SHE IS NOT RUNNING BECAUSE SHE
HAS ANY ANXIETY ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD.
SHE REALLY LIKES A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE RUNNING.
SHE KNOWS THEM WELL.
SHE THOUGHT ABOUT SOME OF THEM.
THERE MIGHT BE A REASON THAT SHE
WOULD BE THE BEST PERSON, NOT
ONLY TO BE DONALD TRUMP, BUT TO
GOVERN AFTER DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CAN MAKE FUN OF FOR ALL YOU
WANT, BUT 65 MILLION PEOPLE
VOTED FOR HER AND THAT
SECOND-MOST --
>> Tucker: I'M NOT MAKING FUN
OF HER
>> I WATCH FOX NEWS.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
HER VERY OFTEN.
>> COME ON.
>> Tucker: AT SO INTERESTING,
HILLARY CLINTON WAS ALWAYS AT
THE LEFT EDGE AND HAS BEEN FOR
50 YEARS SINCE HER 1969 SPEECH,
SHE'S BEEN ON THE LEFTWARD EDGE
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE DENOUNCED BERNIE SANDERS
MEDICARE FOR ALL PROPOSAL IS A
TERRIBLE CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
SHE'S COMPLETELY AGAINST IT.
>> THE LADY KNOWS HER
HEALTH CARE.
SHE WAS AHEAD OF HER TIME IN
1994.
>> Tucker: TO GET THE
NOMINATION?
>> THAT IS NEEDED BY THE PARTY
IS HAVING RIGHT NOW.
THE CANDIDATES WHO ARE FULL
MEDICARE FOR ALL ARE TALKING
ABOUT HOW IT WOULD BE STRUCTURED
AND HE WANTS WAR AGAINST OUR
PRESSING THOSE QUESTIONS.
IF IT'S A HEALTH CARE DEBATE, I
WOULD TAKE THAT.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT JUST
HEALTH CARE.
I WANT TO PUT A QUOTE UP.
THIS IS FROM 2015.
HERE'S HILLARY CLINTON'S
RESPONSE.
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE IS AND HE
SAID HE SHOULD LISTEN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WHICH AS I UNDERSTAND, THEY
SHOULD URGE THEM TO DEPORT THIS
MAN AFTER HE GOT OUT OF PRISON
ANOTHER TIME.
HERE'S A CASE WHERE WE HAVE
DEPORTED, WE'VE DEPORTED AND HE
ENDS UP BACK IN OUR COUNTRY.
I THINK THE CITY MADE A MISTAKE.
THE CITY MADE A MISTAKE NOT TO
DEPORT SOMEONE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, I HAVE NO SUPPORT
FOR A CITY THAT IGNORES THE
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT SHOULD BE
ACTED ON.
WOW.
IF THAT IS NOT RACISM, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS.
>> THAT'S NOT RACISM.
>> Tucker: SHE WANTS TO DEPORT
THE GUY.
>> YOU THINK DEPORTING PEOPLE IS
RACIST?
>> Tucker: I HAVE PERSONALLY
BEEN DENOUNCED AS A RACIST FOR
USING THE WORD DEPORT.
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN FOLLOWING YOUR
PD.
THAT IS RACIST.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE DONALD TRUMP
WHEN SHE WAS PRACTICING FOR HER
DEBATES.
I THREW THOSE QUOTES AT HER LIKE
ANYTHING ELSE.
I THREW THAT AT HER.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN.
THE MAN HAS A RECORD AND HE'S
BEEN THERE FOR THREE YEARS AND
WHILE MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
WAS THE TAGLINE THAT GOT THE
MOST ATTENTION, HE SAID
SOMETHING ELSE WHICH WAS WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
IF WE NOW ASK YOURSELF THAT
QUESTION, 40% OF US ARE GOING TO
SAY WE HAVEN'T LOST ANYTHING.
WE HAVE GAINED.
60% OF US SEEMED TO THINK WE
HAVE LOST.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS AS
IMMIGRATION, PEOPLES FREEDOM AND
HEALTH CARE.
>> Tucker: WHEN SHE SAYS IT'S
NOT RACIST, THAT WAS A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO.
>> ANYBODY WHO RUNS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, IF IT'S A
REFERENDUM ON RACISM.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO IS CALLING FOR EXPLICIT --
PEOPLE ARE KEPT OUT OF JOBS
BECAUSE OF THEIR SKIN COLOR.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS
IMMIGRATION AND I KNOW YOU
BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
PLAN ON IMMIGRATION HAS NOT
WORKED.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU BELIEVED IT
WOULD BE.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS.
JUST LAST WEEK SHE AND HER
DAUGHTER CHELSEA WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE BOOK.
THE SUNDAY TIMES.
>> IT'S A BOOK ABOUT WOMEN
THROUGH THE AGES.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN
INTERVIEW THEY DID WITH A
BRITISH PUBLICATION THE SUNDAY
TIMES AND THEY WERE ASKED, THE
JOURNALIST ASKED THE CLINTONS IF
SOMEBODY WITH A BEARD AND A
PENIS BUT NEVER BECOME A WOMAN,
CHELSEA SAID YES.
HILLARY LOOKED UNEASY AND THEN
SAID THIS, I'M JUST LEARNING
ABOUT THIS.
ERASING TRANS PEOPLE IN THE
PROCESS.
IT'S A VERY BIG GENERATIONAL
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING I GREW UP WITH OR SAW.
IT WILL TAKE A LOT MORE TIME AND
EFFORT TO BE UNDERSTOOD ABOUT
DIVIDING YOURSELF DIFFERENTLY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS
TRANSPHOBIA.
>> THE COMMUNITY KNOWS WHERE SHE
STANDS.
SHE MADE SURE TO GIVE PASSPORTS
TO PEOPLE AND RELATIONSHIPS.
SHE MADE SURE THAT IF THEY HAD A
HEALTH PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S DIFFERENT.
EVERYONE BUNDLES THIS ALL
TOGETHER.
THIS IS A VERY SPECIFIC QUESTION
ABOUT TRANS ORTHODOXY AND
HILLARY CLINTON IS LIKE, IT
MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE, THAT'S
CREEPY.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY THAT.
>> IF SHE WERE TO RUN WHICH IS
UNLIKELY.
IF YOU GIVE ME A CHOICE BETWEEN
BETTING ON HER RUNNING OR
PARABLE, PEOPLE GET TO DECIDE.
IT'S A COTTAGE INDUSTRY.
TO SOME EXTENT, SHE MIGHT AS
WELL GROWN.
>> Tucker: SHE'S BECOME THE
MOST REASONABLE PERSON ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.